we now have the capacity for a hundred
and sixty one thousand tests a day and
because of that increased capacity I can
announce that we're expanding
eligibility yet further from tomorrow
we're expanding eligibility for testing
to include the under fives so that now
every single person who has symptoms of
corona virus can get a test no matter
their age and what's more to make NHS
tests and trace as effective as possible
it is very important that everyone with
symptoms must isolate immediately and go
and get a test now I want to thank and
pay tribute to everyone who's been
involved in making this big project
happen Dido Harding who's led the work
the technicians in the labs who've been
making mass testing a reality the
contact tracers Manning the phones the
health care staff providing the expert
advice and the companies who've helped
us put it all together at a record scale
and pace and what really matters is this
to protect your friends and your family
testing and tracing must become a new
way of life this is being launched today
in England Northern Ireland already has
a system in place and my colleagues in
the Scottish and Welsh governments are
working to bring in a system as soon as
they can all four nations have been
working together to make sure we have
systems that are coordinated across the
whole country and the instructions to
people are clear if you get symptoms
isolate immediately and get a test if
you are contacted by NHS tests and trace
instructing you to isolate you must it
is your civic duty so you avoid
unknowingly spreading the virus and you
help to break the chain of transmission
this will be voluntary at first because
we trust everyone to do the right thing
but we can quickly make it mandatory if
that's what it takes
because if we don't collectively make
this work then the only way forward is
to keep the lock down put better the
more people follow the instructions the
safer we will be and the faster we can
safely lift the lockdown so do it for
the people you love
do it for your community do it for the
NHS and do it for all those frontline
workers who've done so much and gone out
every day to put themselves at risk to
keep you and your family safe and in
return for following those instructions
you'll have the knowledge that when the
call came you did your bit at a time
when it really mattered when the whole
country who are desperate to see their
families we're counting on you to do the
right thing you did your bit to bring us
all closer together and closer to the
day when we can be reunited this system
will start tomorrow morning at 9:00 a.m.
and the first people who'll be contacted
will be the people who received a
positive result today this is a very
distinct change on our approach and I
just want to take a moment to recap the
extent of the change before today we
said isolate to anyone with coronavirus
symptoms and their households this
remains a vital from 9:00 a.m. tomorrow
in addition if you are contacted by an
NHS test and trace advisor advising you
that you must isolate then you must do
that whether you have symptoms or not
now I also know that for those without
symptoms who receive that call I fully
acknowledge that this is a big ask and
that you're going to make a sacrifice
but it's for a purpose and the purpose
is the safety of everyone because we
know that you can have the virus and
spread it to other people without ever
having symptoms at all and it's not just
the safety of all but the liberty at all
of all that is at stake here
we're only in a position to be able to
reopen primary schools and outdoor
markets if their covert secure this
coming Monday because we've flattened
the curve and now we have this system in
place and in the coming weeks we will
gradually and very carefully move away
from a lockdown this national in scope
blanketing application and start moving
towards a system that's much more
targeted in scope and focuses local
action on tackling local flare-ups this
will help us restore some of the basic
freedoms that matter so much to people
and doing some of the things that people
are yearning to do like seeing friends
and family booking a holiday or getting
a haircut
all the while controlling the virus and
keeping people safe it's a brand new
service on a scale never seen before
there will be bumps in the road but we
will constantly improve it and in the
weeks ahead we'll ramp up the service
still further and once the system's
bedded in we'll roll out the NHS contact
tracing app that is being piloted in the
Isle of Wight and of course NHS tests
and trace is only one part of the answer
it's not the whole answer all the action
we're taking to get our down and keep
our down it all requires us to keep
doing the right thing
testing and tracing will help us to hunt
down this virus it's one of the tools
with which we can finish the job and we
all need to play our part so please stay
alert control the virus and save lives
I'm now going to ask
Baroness Harding to set out some more of
the details of NHS tests and trace and
then professor van tam to take us
through the daily statistics Thank You
Secretary of State this is a brand new
service which has been launched at scale
in a very short space of time and as the
secretary state has just said we all
have a part to play and it will only
succeed if each of us does our bit I
want you to feel safe and confident to
play an active part in NHS tests and
trace for you your loved ones and our
country we do need you to follow the
following 3-step
it's step one if you have one or more of
the symptoms of coronavirus a fever a
new continuous cough or a loss of your
sense of taste or smell you must
immediately self isolate step two you
should then book a test on the NHS dot
uk' slash coronavirus site or if you
don't have internet access by dialing
one one nine do not leave home for any
other reason if you test positive you
will then be contacted by the NHS test
and trace service within 24 hours all
contact races have been undergoing
training and induction before the
beginning of this week and before they
start work step 3 NHS tests and trace
will help you establish who you've been
in close contact with and so who you
might have infected and will gather
their contact details
this could include members of your
household or someone you've been within
2 metres off for more than 15 minutes
you will also be given clinical advice
and support for dealing with the disease
yourself NHS tests and trace and turn
will get in touch with those contacts so
if you've been exposed to an infected
person they will be in contact with you
you will then be instructed by the NHS
to self isolate for 14 days even if you
don't have symptoms or you feel
perfectly well you need to follow these
instructions this individual and
collective effort is vital if we're to
keep the rate of infection down and
carefully lift the lockdown we're
working hand in hand with communities
and local authorities to make sure that
you have the support you need to cope
when you are self isolating this is why
the government announced last week it's
giving 300 million pounds to local
government to support this on-the-ground
tailoring support in response to your
local needs over the past few days and
weeks I've spoken to a huge number of
people and I've heard real support
and a desire to make this work we all
want to get back to a more normal way of
life and this is an important step on
that journey